andere youtuber stecken tausende von
euros in fifa packs kaufte sich extrem
seltene pokémon karten oder zocken den
ganzen tag minecraft und dann gibt es
nicht herzlich willkommen zum topclub
spieletag pakt nicht selber an sie
beinen und stopfe sich in münster du
kleine tagesrate wir starten einfach mal
mit meinem lieblings spiel und zwar dem
schnellen ritt ja das kann nur gut
werden wir warten jetzt einfach mal im
wald von villa lobos und müssen jetzt
mit unserem fährt ein rennen bestreiten
oder was müssen überhaupt tun wie
steuern wir das ding überhaupt h
das ist jetzt immer tot wir leben noch
sagt weitergeht unsere fahrt ihr über
hier müssen wir sind so gut also unser
ziel ist es um die hindernisse
rumzulaufen beziehungsweise wenn so ein
baum liegt darüber zu springen ich weiß
nicht warum das gerade nicht ging mit
der leertaste allerdings das ist jetzt
nicht das ziel oder
das ist jetzt aber weder ein fahrrad
natürlich den schwereren fordert krieg
war im freundes oder links liegt ein
stein da liechtenstein jetzt kommt
springt ihr habt wirst du der einzige um
die steine um das ist ja alles riesig
und jetzt ja das sogar gehört ich
verlier bei dem kinderspiel
ich drücke auf die taste das ist jetzt
nicht wahr das ist jetzt nicht wahr
das spiel ist für zweijährige wir haben
uns ja eigentlich eh nur wegen der
schneeballschlacht versammelt schnee
schpakow 69 8 uhr grünen wären wir sogar
waffen und so was alles zur auswahl
ich würde allerdings sagen wir kriegen
einfach mal direkt aufs spiel starten ek
dass das scheint ja richtig krank dass
es online also wir müssen hier
entscheiden die leute abknallen und
stimmt der typ nicht warum stirbt der
typ nicht erst jetzt online oder ist das
irgendwie so ein computer gesteuert
hatte mir das wieder online sein
wie grant wissen dass 2020 und wir
spielen spiele online im internet
aber so jetzt verstehe ich den apparat
ja auch das hier sind unsere gegner
diese rot sind und wir sind die blauen
müssen die roten haid töten wie man das
bei einer wir haben machen wir weiter
mit der dynamit akademie eine ahnung
rummste geht aber wir müssen glaube ich
dass die amis hier reinpacken und dann
springen und dann haben level nummer
zwei wir platzieren hier ein dynamit
hier ein dynamit und dann nochmal hier
oben rheins und jetzt sprechen wir mit
profi level nummer drei der hier in
dynamit und hier vorne ein wieder mit
sprengung ganz nah baral und wir haben
es geschafft
ich nehme hier ein dynamit und hier ein
dynamit an das kriege ich das ja nicht
hin ich muss er das rechts weg hauen und
das und bahn
warum scheitern ich anspielen die 42
jährige ausgelegt sind ich platz jetzt
einfach mal hier ein dynamit und hier
vorne vielleicht macht das ja sinn weil
wir dass die front so so
und da wir haben jetzt eine brandbombe
bekommen keine ahnung was jetzt macht
allerdings brennt die wahrscheinlich ja
das sagt der name dann eigentlich auch
schon jetzt haben eine normale und eine
brandbombe also ich würde die normale
einfach mal hier rein packen und die
brandbombe hier direkt ans holz
ich sollte dass wir nicht aufgeben
das macht keinen spaß bot eishockey je
länger nur am stein schießt er so
weiterspielt hat der puck bla bla bla
bla bla ja also ich soll schon denken so
der schwarz ist der pokal das war der
computer die spielen gegen bari und
fangen an das heißt in dem jetzt die
stinkenden wir nicht
das ist ja ok barbies aber ziemlich blöd
von daher können wir jetzt eigentlich
direkt jede bude machen
[Musik]
der scheiß boston barbie so richtig toll
gegen den putsch ist dran und will ja
das ist super und jetzt klasse das ist
das war quasi dann für mich weil jetzt
nämlich den bau der barbie wieder ein
tor rein nicht so blöde guck mal was sie
jetzt machen wir gar nicht mal so
schlecht barbie allerdings hast du dann
die rechnung ohne mich gemacht ich mache
jetzt so über die bande geht dagegen
rein
mal schauen was wir hier veranstaltet
das ja
jetzt fast den puck berührt jetzt kommt
ihr comeback des jahrtausends hier beim
so so so unberührt
täglich über ein spiel auf was ich
wahrscheinlich gerade gegen ein mädchen
aus der ersten klasse spiele
[Applaus]
er ist hier wirklich not gegen elend
so
ich hab's mal sehen was du davon
hast du blödmann warriors germany kids
ninja anleger hätten aber nicht sein
können müssen jetzt mit unserem ninja
schnellstmöglichen ziel kommen hier
vorne werden wir schneller und dann
müssen wir hierdurch und hier drüber ich
habe bisher kein bisschen gesteuert muss
denn überhaupt irgendwas machen
[Musik]
also das ist selbst mir zu einfach
ballabriggs hat jemand im club auf
mallorca an wir können uns aussuchen ob
wir sich oder schalke sind
ich habe ehrlich gesagt von beiden angst
ach so das ist so worms mäßig
unternehmen unseren steinen und haben
ihn voll gegen seine festung hier
wie dann eben vielleicht vorher sagen
dass seine festung da hinten ist und
nicht dieser kleine kag wert wo soll ich
das denn er wissen daher geben jetzt ein
bisschen höher bisschen weiter so dem
gas plus 70 punkte als folge rutschte so
wilkens leighton
[Musik]
anders hätte mich das heutige video
allerdings auch beenden meine lieben
freunde wenn otto bohl die kinderspiele
mit luca gefallen haben und die
bordwaffen zwei klassen daumen hoch
unter video das schreibt susan die
kommentare und ich folge dir dabei den
letzten 1000 videos vergessenen
adventskalender aufzumachen von dann
machen wir das jetzt im schnelldurchlauf
in türchen nummer 5 befindet sich ein
busch zürcher nummer 6 vom nikolaus da
haben wir ja den osterhasen natürliche
nummer 7 meiner liebe freunde verbietet
sich
ein sack ist er ein anzeichen eine
beobachtung noch kein trend durch die
nummer 8 behält
der weihnachtsmann kräfte selbst nicht
gewusst und natürlich komplett
tagesaktuell auch türchen nummer 9 in
dem wir alt
wenn wir kasten drinnen haben ja wenn
ich meine liste ist jetzt auch instagram
und leicht das neue bild von laser luca